okay uh i've not been covering the
recent
white house press briefings very much
it's mostly
very procedural and sort of perfunctory
announcements combined with relatively
benign and sometimes dumb questions from
the press corps
and i hate that that's how i'm breaking
it down but i think it reflects the
reality of recent press briefings but
this past
friday there was a really great example
of white house press secretary jen saki
using super basic simple
epistemology techniques that i've talked
about on the program
for a very long time to make a newsmax
reporter i guess they're calling her a
reporter attempting gotcha questions
look like the fool that she is and you
you really have to look at this clip
almost second by second because it's a
veritable treasure trove of
instructive critical thinking material i
won't even tell you anything about
what's in the clip let's just start the
clip
see if you can start identifying the
logical fallacies here
thanks jen i have questions on a couple
different topics first
given the number of former obama
administration officials that are now in
this biden administration
and the president's relatively light
schedule there's a growing perception
that this is really just the third term
of president obama okay so already
we have conclusions that do not follow
from premises
and we have false premises this is basic
basic critical thinking stuff the
premises are
and she actually says given that that's
how you know it's a premise
given that there are obama officials in
this administration
and given that joe biden is keeping a
very light
schedule now these are terrible premises
there are obama officials in this
administration
just like every administration has
officials from prior administrations
it's not unique
it doesn't tell us very much one way or
the other second
given joe biden's light schedule this is
part of the
biden senile and demented and can't do
anything
joe biden doesn't have a light schedule
he has a completely normal presidential
schedule
given that there's a pandemic still
going on trump did not work
for the final six to eight months of his
presidency he golfed
on nearly 20 of the days of his
presidency so
two false premises and the conclusion
by definition has to be false but also
it's false because uh there is
this is not an obama third term it did
what does that even mean
false false premises conclusion doesn't
follow
let's continue going back a few seconds
and then going further forward
and the president's relatively light
schedule there's a growing perception
that this
is really just the third term of
president obama what do you say to
people who say that
who were saying that who's saying that
you hear that a lot in the media
who in the media different people okay
so jen
saki well done well done trump uh uh
uh people are saying says the trumpian
reporter she turns it into well who is
saying that
who exactly the reporter has nothing and
look at what happens next
like well there was lots of questions uh
about
when you had japanese prime minister
suga here
on the one and only so far in person
bilateral
head of state meeting it was vice
president kamala harris
who greeted the prime minister many
people found that odd
okay so now we get an example but still
many people found that odd
well hold on a second what people media
people politicians
random voters who are you talking about
she's already taking
independent one-on-one calls with key
allies like
prime minister morrison and justin
trudeau so
i just want to get your reaction to
people who question that
well it's hard to react when i don't
know what people you're talking about i
will say that the president
met with the prime minister as you know
and had a full meeting
a full press conference afterwards and
they even shared a meal
so and the president has had dozens of
conversations and calls with world
leaders and should be no surprise that
the vice president is also playing an
important role
engaging with and having discussions
with foreign leaders
there's really nothing there as you can
see
this was false premises a bogus
conclusion from those premises
and then an out of context single
example
when she just said well there's all of
these different examples
and she's able to come up only with one
and it's weak and it's barely connected
to what they're talking about
this stuff falls apart under basic
questioning
supply side economics implodes if you
ask
two or three basic questions debt
deficit
political football talking points they
fall apart
they have to be questioned and it really
doesn't take exotic methods to expose
the stuff and
a lot of times people will call in and
they'll say to me how do i
deal with at the thanksgiving table my
crazy trumpy
uncle saying this that or the other
thing and very often you know if you
don't want to start a huge fight
it's just about asking how they came to
know
or believe the things that they tell you
and it will very
quickly fall apart let's look at a
little bit more now this is the same
reporter
apparently named emerald trying some
other gotchas the first one didn't work
on gen saki
so she moved on to some other gotchas on
to dr fauci conspiracies and other
things take a look
that the nih and dr fauci
had provided funding to the wuhan lab of
virology that's the lead 11 question
when we talk about the lab leak theory
and
given that gain and function research is
dicey why would the us fund that in
china
i'm happy to send you to the nih about
more specifics of what program they
funded and more details of that now i do
have one more follow-up on that because
the president hasn't really weighed in
dr fauci
is one of the voices who discredit the
lab league theory but now there's more
officials
in the binding administration like the
the director of national intelligence
the cia director
and now also the nih director who say
that this cannot be ruled out and
there's calls for more investigation
into it
who does the president agree with dr
falchi or the other officials does he
think this
it was a loud leak well the president
has said and i've said from here many
times that
there needs to be a credible independent
investigation
through the world health organization
and that one that relies on data relies
on participation from china
and other uh countries that may have
information that's certainly something
everybody has called for and we look
forward to that
happening spoken with president xi about
the origins of the corona virus yet he
said
uh just a few weeks ago he hadn't yet uh
i think we have given a readout of his
call and also that the president
believes there should be an independent
investigation led by health
experts um and one where their data is
provided that's provided transparently
to our medical
uh and science experts here in the
united states and we look forward to
reviewing that
we're gonna have to go on i'm sorry
emerald i think you've had plenty of
time today
go ahead uh go ahead really embarrassing
i mean if these people were able to feel
shame she should be leaving with her
tail between her legs
and never showing her face in that
briefing room again i'm not even sure
how she's in the briefing room quite
frankly but that's another topic
altogether
i know that jen saki has young kids
she deals with these reporters almost
like dealing with little kids
you've gotten enough time i let you say
your thing i've humored you
let me go on to somebody else now okay
kiddo we can do more tomorrow
maybe if she's allowed back in well done
there
but it's not you know there's nothing
exotic or special that's happening it's
just well hold on
let's listen to what you're saying and
actually figure out if there's anything
behind it
this is a really good technique we've
talked about it before
and i'm sure that we will talk about it
again let's take a quick break make sure
you're following me
on twitter dpakman and we'll be back
right after this
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wrist watch is the
perfect way
to elevate your style own at least one
watch that makes you feel great when you
put it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy and
five year warranty they'll give you 15
off everything in their store and free
shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman